what is the value of connecting the
other five billion how do we get there
and is it worth the effort
well conductivity some an amazing thing
whether it's connecting up a health
center so we can help see that the
stocks are there and give advice to
worker who may not be trained as a
doctor getting connectivity to school
rooms is a fantastic thing there are
many important things education and good
government's having a measles vaccine so
kids aren't dying of that and you know
we have to prioritize those things but
it's wonderful that connectivity will be
an enabler transparency for better
government education and health it's one
of the many things that will help us do
a better job when the tsunami at South
Asia and we put we did everything we
could put all the fishing families back
in the water when they all lost their
boats and in Aceh in Indonesia and in
Sri Lanka we gave them all with the new
boats a cell phone
the average incomes went up 30% once
people could know what the price of fish
was just 30 miles down the way after the
Haiti earthquake we realized that 85% or
more of the people had no access to
banking services because the six big
banks there could make more than enough
money in an easier way by taking all the
remittances from Haitians working around
the world converting them into local
currencies charging a fee and then you
spend the rest a day reading the
newspaper so we got a Canadian banks
Costa Bank to partner with did you sell
the biggest cell phone company to offer
basic consumer banking services over the
Internet if you don't have connectivity
can't do that stuff and we're just
beginning this we're just beginning